der gipfel zwischen donald trump und kim
jong un ist geplatzt
ja aber hätte es so schön werden können
mit kimi und strich aber ja und alle
fragen sich ist das jetzt schon das ende
dieser wunderbaren männerfreundschaft
man muss es befürchten man muss es
befürchten und tatsächlich war ja schon
die allererste begegnung in hanoi ja
irgendwie krampfig stehen darum die
clowns wie bestellt und nicht abgeholt
dann drehen sich um 8 guck mal fahren
von welchem land keine ahnung und sonst
so ja muss ja totaler krampf und dann
endet das auch noch ohne abkommen
riesenüberraschung
kim jong un hat sogar das gemeinsame
mittagessen ausfallen lassen
und wenn der kim auf ein essen
verzichtet
dann ist wirklich fast atomkrieg freunde
so bitter donald trump hatte den
nobelpreis doch praktisch schon in der
tasche
der neue friedensfürsten so knaps
versuch nordkoreas regime sieht
atomwaffen als lebensversicherung genau
daran sind alle verhandlungen mit denen
seit jahrzehnten gescheitert das weiß
jeder
nur der große deal maker dachte er kann
den kinder irgendwie weil sie nicht rein
labern ein klein bisschen viel
komplimente vielleicht für einen
brutalen diktator der sein eigenes volk
verhungern lässt und den arbeitslager
sperrt was sich aber toll fand das kind
mit dem zug nach her neu gefahren ist
oder das war super wegen co2 bilanz und
so hat sich der kleine jim knopf kind
knopf viel mehr nämlich extra ein
interrail ticket gekauft und dann die
namen von allen aufgeschrieben die nicht
zurück winken ja nix war's mit der
ersehnten denuklearisierung von korea
und das ist besonders ärgerlich für
mister trump denn während er da in
vietnam war mit schweinchen dick hat ja
in washington sein ehemaliger anwalt vor
dem kongress ausgepackt michael kohn
das ist gesehen und vor dem kongress ja
kohl sagt wörtlich trump ist ein rassist
hochstapler und betrüger
nein wirklich was hat er denn
rassistisches gesagt wenn die tommy hat
brad pitt bohème begrüßt tust du bist du
dumm ich dachte im tram zu werden kann
man gar nicht dumm genug sein
ja viele schwarze würden niemals einen
orangen wählen dass meine theorie was
haben wir noch gelernt trump hat wohl im
wahlkampf doch geschäfte mit russland
gemacht
schweigegeld an porno stars gezahlt und
ausdrücklich kein witz seine ehemalige
schule bedroht niemals seine zeugnisse
zu veröffentlichen diese cohen befragung
war wie eine szene aus einem mafiafilm
[Musik]
hat er scheinbar buch geführt
[Applaus]
so um die 500 mal frühjahr sie erinnern
sich hätte ein bruchteil von all dem was
wir gerade gehört haben für einen
rücktritt gereicht aber es ist halt
nicht mehr früher wie gesagt ganz blöde
woche für donald trump und der traurige
schlusspunkt einer unvergesslichen
romance
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen die ihre texte kritiken liegen
und ihr lasst jetzt dass selbst ein
beschissenes autobahn
[Musik]